not every chillin horsey makes it to the
big screen
whether for pacing reasons keeping the
MPAA rating and an accessible are for
simply the filmmakers going in a
different direction these scenes were
left on the cutting room floor but
they're no less terrifying on their own
here are some of the scariest deleted
scenes from your favorite horror movies
but beware the spoilers the cocoon room
there were a lot of ideas that never
came to fruition and Ridley Scott's
alien well what we were left with was
still a groundbreaking extraterrestrial
thriller often imitated never quite
matched the plot follows a commercial
space crew awoken from stasis after
receiving a signal from an alien craft
they're overrun by the bloodthirsty
extraterrestrial monster with officer
Ripley emerging as the central heroine
and only survivor one of the deleted
scenes from the film might have answered
a few questions left about the alien and
escalated the fear factor in this cocoon
room scene Ripley happens upon the trap
bodies of the deceased Brett and is
still alive Dallas whose whereabouts
were otherwise unknown after they ran
into the creature in the original cut as
an act of mercy Ripley has to fire blast
Dallas which is pretty raw even for
alien the baboon cat the fly is a
seminal piece of horror with or without
its scariest deleted scene the sci-fi
thriller followed Seth Brundle as he
became a victim of his own oddball
scientific experiments he slowly morphed
into a human fly hybrid that was
desperate to save his new species by
making a baby with his human girlfriend
in this deleted scene even though
grundles teleportation experience has
clearly altered his own DNA he's still
splicing animals together in his lab
this time it's a baboon and a house cat
which when combined becomes a two-headed
Sharptooth beast that goes on the attack
and has to be exterminated it might have
been a bit too obvious as foreshadowing
if left in but the scene definitely
doesn't offer much hope for Brundle Zone
future as a fellow lab mutant yeah
visions of hell event horizon is filled
with stomach-churning imagery the movie
followed a space crew as he attempted to
make contact with a vessel and was
temporarily lost to a black hole and
layered itself with disturbing visuals
before jumping headlong into a living
nightmare
but as sinister as the scenes of the
space inferno already are the movie's
original vision of the bad place was
even more disturbing
pure chaos pure in this deleted scene
dr. William ware has been fully
transformed into the slash face demon
that haunts the ship and its remaining
crew and captain Miller is chased down
and treated to an extreme vision of the
other side impaled limb rip bodies are
on display as the living are tied down
and tortured the plights of these human
souls may differ slightly but the
suffering is universal given the graphic
nature of this footage it's not hard to
see why an abbreviated version was
ultimately what made it into theaters
even Dante might have shuddered at the
sight of this much under worldly
punishment
dr. Satan's last lunge with the Devil's
Rejects writer director Rob Zombie took
a decidedly different approach to the
McCobb that he did with its predecessor
House of a thousand corpses rather than
relying on gruesome imagery in the lo
some lair of the Firefly family the
movie leaned harder and a slow burn of
emotional torture and depravity as it
followed the three lead escapees through
one final round of destruction for that
reason this deleted scene wasn't a good
fit in the clip we meet dr. Satan again
the characters twisted experimental
surgeries featured prominently in the
first film and in rejects he's been
captured by the authorities but he isn't
as subdued as they think his
unsuspecting nurse gets her throat
ripped out after he awakens from his
feigned coma and the move is so quick
that the police and medical personnel
can do nothing to stop her from bleeding
out on the hospital floor the Tilted
room the adaptation of Stephen King's
1408 follows a skeptical haunted house
story author as he rents out a deadly
hotel room that's claimed the lives of
dozens of occupants over the last
century what happens next is a bit
formulaic but is bolstered by sensory
immersion with enough paranormal
surprises and emotional scenes to stick
in this deleted scene John Cusack's
estranged wife has been summoned to the
hotel by a supernatural doppelganger and
he's powerless to stop her from trying
to enter the room as he tries to get
close to prevent her from joining him
the room tilts to a degree that disables
him from reaching the door for all the
elemental frights the room provided this
had to be the most disorienting despite
being deleted the final cut the
theatrically released ending of
paranormal activity was pretty upsetting
in the film Katie and Myka are a young
couple who've moved to the wrong house
at the wrong time and can't shake the
terrorizing spirits that came with it
despite their best efforts to exorcise
the evil spirits from their home Katie
is eventually possessed by the
in spirit and appears to n Mika by
summoning him downstairs and then
hurling his bloody body at the camera
they've been using to document their
haunting she then shuffles on-screen
looks at the camera and offers a smile
that makes it clear she's given herself
over to evil in the original ending
though Katy returns to the bedroom and
what appears to be a trance and sits
rocking on the floor as time passes
eventually the police show up find
Micah's body and make their way upstairs
to Katy she snaps out of her trance but
police believe she's a threat and
shooter the scariest version though is
the alternate ending when instead of
launching Micah's body at the camera she
returns to the frame herself covered in
blood and holding her kitchen knife
which she then uses on herself chances
are this one was passed over because it
would have ended the hit franchise
before it began but still what a way to
go thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]